who do you expect to go back to work
today well we're saying in relation to
the existing guidelines that if you can
work from home you still should but for
those who can't work from home thinking
particularly the construction the
manufacturing sectors we are encouraging
them to go back to work actively now
that won't start until Wednesday so
there'll be guidance out we've been
working with the employers to make sure
it can be done the safe way and this is
the first step in the roadmap over the
next weeks ahead as we transition out
from the current restrictions and we
protect life but we also protect
people's livelihoods and get back as
close as we reasonably responsibly can
to our way of life so it's the first
step we'll proceed with maximum
conditions maximum monitoring but I
think it's right and we can do so in a
short footage way okay construction
workers who else well this is a relation
to those who can't stay at home and do
their job so construction is a really
important sector manufacturing we're
going to set out the full list at two
o'clock this afternoon with a 50 page
document there'll be further guidance
for employers around that so it's really
talking about those who I mean if you
can still work from home that is the
thing that we are advising you to do but
of course there are large sectors the
economy which is can't operate that way
and so having worked with employers
having worked with those businesses to
make sure that safe and secure kovetz
secured settings can can be provided for
people we're saying that actually from
Wednesday they should get back to work
people like hairdressers can't tell you
how many people have been asking me
about hairdressers what are they need to
do they can't work from home can they
know absolutely not and we will as I
said this is the first step on Wednesday
there are three steps so from the
earliest 1st of June we'll look at
non-essential retail and how they can go
back only if the conditions are met
subject to wider monitoring so that we
only proceed inshore footed way and then
from the fourth of July at the earliest
subject to the conditions we'll look at
other sectors and that will include
hospitality but it will also include
personal care and and people at
hairdressers and obviously the proximity
in those two sectors that I've mentioned
hospitality and personal care sector
like
hairdressers is something well we just
don't think we're ready yet given where
we are with the virus so we've got very
clear guidance will be coming out to
give people the information that they
need but as I said our overriding goal
is to make sure we protect people's
health we we don't see the virus get out
of control that's why we need to stay
alert but we also start to protect
livelihoods and preserve our way of life
as best we can in these circumstances
okay so they're gonna have to wait until
Independence Day to potentially get back
to work hairdressers hospitality like
does that mean pubs as well does that
mean pubs and restaurants will start to
reopen in July because if they don't
that sector potentially is going under
yeah you're absolutely right so there's
three steps there's the modest changes
we're announcing which will take effect
from Wednesday there's the other changes
for things like non-essential retail and
people going back to school particularly
primary school which won't start until
the earliest on the 1st of June subject
convicted conditions and then starting
from the fourth of July at the very
earliest those other sectors where
they're just inherently more difficult
because people are mixing together and
it's difficult to maintain the social
distancing we wouldn't be able to say
based on the advice we get and the
monitoring we do that we would start
them at least at least until the fourth
of July but we do want to give people
the signal businesses but also the
public sector so that we can plan and
have a plan and have guidance and start
to prepare for if that's possible and
every step along the way as we said
we've got to stay alert we've got to
monitor very carefully the progress
we've made with the virus we've got to
keep getting it down both the overall
prevalence but also the transmission
rate and then we'll see where we get to
but but I do think it's important on a
road map along the way yeah but just
drilling down on that are you suggesting
that pubs potentially and restaurants
could pubs and restaurants could start
to reopen on the 4th of July so the full
detail be set out in this 50 page
document found at 2 o'clock this
afternoon but what we're saying is those
wouldn't even be considered until step 3
which would be at the very earliest 4th
of June subject to all the conditions
that I've mentioned about making sure
the virus is under control and making
sure that any new sectors at that point
that are open could be done
in a covert secure way which is why I
was saying we've got to stay alert
control this virus as we start to get
back to something resembling normal but
but that's the if you like the milestone
that we've set for consideration of
things like pubs and restaurants okay
out in the park you can go out in the
park and you can sit as long as as long
as you're socially distancing from one
other person in in the park but what am
i in the garden can you have somebody
around another question that I was asked
overnight can you can you have somebody
who is a part of your household around
in your garden as long as you're sitting
two meters away from them well the full
detail in it will be set out in the
guidance at two o'clock but effectively
what we're saying yes but I've seen but
effectively what we're saying is that if
you can stay two meters apart as is
already the case for example with
shopping deliveries or support for the
vulnerable if you can stay two meters
apart then we want to really encourage
people to use their common sense but but
we do need to maintain that social
distancing if not and people have been
exceptional so far the overwhelming
majority of people and followed the
guidance the guidelines that's why we've
got the level of this virus down to the
stage we've got it at now and if we stay
alert and we keep that social distancing
that I mentioned whatever the setting it
may be we can keep making progress and
get more of the things back to normal
that people would like whether it's
schools whether it's business whether
it's socialising but we must maintain
the two measures apart okay you
understand why that's important though
don't you mr. up a lot of people have
been been apart from their older
relatives for many many weeks now and
they wanted just to be able to go around
and sit in the garden with them Stephen
King that previously was spoken to by
police we're doing that you're saying
that's no longer people can now
potentially do that well no let me be
clear about that I know exactly what you
mean my mum's birthday was over the
weekend it's difficult I know for
families up and down the country what
we've asked is we've asked the
scientists to look at whether there
could be some limited contact between
say two different households within the
same family in is the example you've
given and we've asked them to give us
some advice on what that would do to the
transmission rate so until we've got
that advice back week
in position say yes you can you can
positively do that but it is something
we want to look at because for all the
reasons that you express Kay we can see
why people want to be more in touch with
their close family many happy returns to
your mum when will it be safe to travel
on public transport again well we're
going to set out the guidance on that on
Tuesday we're working very closely with
both for example London TfL and all the
other operators but we're saying at the
moment please do avoid we recognize that
for example if people are going back to
work construction and manufacturing
where we've said that if you can't work
from home go back to work
we recognize that we'll be people that
want to we're saying wherever possible
either go by car cycling or or walking
if you possibly can and we're making
arrangements in relation to public
transport for those that that literally
can't so we still want to keep people
off public transport at this stage
because of course there's a greater risk
of that mixing and avoiding the social
distancing but we'll set out clear
guidance and on Tuesday in relation to
public transport and if you have to go
by public transport you need to wear a
face mask gloves etc where'd you get
them from so just on face coverings and
that's distinct from the kind of face
mask clinical-grade that you would
expect in either the NHS or care homes
there's limited evidence on their value
but one thing they can do in settings
where you can't be guaranteed that
you'll be socially distance they can
stop you pass it on to other people so
that's something which in relation to
public transport is something that will
give advice on shortly about how that
can be done but it but it's not as I
said it's not clinical grade masks it
will be the kind of face covering that
you could prepare and make at home and
again as well I mean I see I've seen
them the Marines on on YouTube showing
me how to make a mask I saw Prince Harry
wandering out and about in LA with with
with just a scarf over his face that
sort of DIY face covering would be
sufficient would
yes and let's be clear about the limits
of it it also has a limited effect in
terms of stopping other people from
receiving the virus from someone that
wears the covering it's not going to
provide any additional protection for
the person wearing it but in the areas
where you just can't be sure that you
might not run into people that you don't
know or that you find yourself feeling
they're more enclosed spaces than you
would you would otherwise want to be and
given the social distancing rules it
just provides an extra mitigation so we
will be giving advice on that in on
Tuesday and further detail on that in
the 50 page document will be out today
okay two final quick questions this has
been very enlightening for exactly thank
you schools back on the 1st of June for
the first tranche the older ones
potentially not back till September is
that what I was picking up from the
prime minister yesterday yes so from the
1st of June that's the earliest that we
would start saying to reception children
in primary schools year 1 and year 6 and
all two to go back but only if the
conditions are satisfied if it's both
safe in terms of their progress we're
making with a virus but also that the
social distancing measures can be put in
place in in schools we're also saying
because we know that they'll be
youngsters in secondary schools who've
got GCC's or a-levels next year those
that face exams next year we want to
make sure they have some access to their
teachers before they go away for the
summer term our ambition is to get all
primary school children back into school
by within a month of the end of the
summer term but again as I said all
along only if these conditions can be
satisfied so that we can proceed on a
shore foot it's safe way responsible way
but we recognize that it's important for
young people's education but also for
people who want to go back to work so
that wouldn't happen until at the very
earliest the first at you okay and as
far as airports are concerned it looks
as though with this 14-day quarantine
that it looks as though you're likely to
introduce that you are torpedoing the
summer holiday industry under the
waterline
well look the reality is we've been
looking at border restrictions
restrictions at airports and ports for
some time I've consistently asked the
question is this a an effective measure
that we should be taking the answers
come back no not while the virus is
transmitting at the rate inside the UK
that it is but now we've got it down
there is a risk that people that come in
from abroad who may not appear to other
symptoms but are carrying the virus
could then revive the virus in the UK so
we'll we're not doing it immediately
will work but towards the end of the
month to put this in place but what we
will do which is for I think it's only
90 countries have already done this and
there are different steps on the way so
we've always said we'll take the right
decision at the right moment in time but
we are saying that people who have come
into this country from that point would
need to go into isolation for 14 days
and that just stops as we bring the
virus down it stops it resurging so and
we'll talk to our international partners
and make sure international Freight can
keep coming we'll make sure and that
there are certain exceptions for example
in Northern Ireland the common travel
area will be retained will speak to the
French the Prime Minister's already
spoken to president back on to make sure
there are common-sense measures across
the short straights so I'll do it in a
practical way but it just it gives us an
extra check and extra precaution so that
we don't see the virus as it comes down
start to pick up again because of
asymptomatic people people are not
showing the symptoms coming in from
abroad why did we do this ages ago
because as I said the science was that
when the level of the virus both the
prevalence the amount of it but also the
rate of transmission was within the UK
very high it made no difference
what war negligible difference what what
restrictions we put at the border but as
the virus comes down the risk that it
could suddenly pick up again because of
people carrying the virus you may not be
aware of it coming into the UK and
spreading it so that's the reality and
as we've said all along we'll be guided
by the scientific advice and we'll take
the measures at the right moment in time
and the key thing is as we go through
the the phases and the roadmap we need
to protect life we need to make sure the
public health is the number one priority
but we also need to protect people's
livelihoods and get life back to
somewhere resembling normal
and for that reason we need to stay
alert so that we control the virus as we
start to allow people to do more of the
things that they they would want to do
and as we proceed safely and securely
into the second phase